and now
false flags that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now a popular liberal on social media
noah smith tweeted something this week
that spoke volumes about the democrats
political desperation
with inflation thermostatic politics and
now uh likely economic slowdown well
dems best hope for the midterms is
probably to use a rally round the flag
appeal by bashing russia hard and
emphasizing trumper's ties to putin
not just that
okay if you can believe that one they're
now throwing around the t word because
tulsi gabbard dared to question the rush
to war mindset mitt romney got very
angry
tulsi gabbard is parroting false russian
propaganda her treasonous lies may well
cost lives
and the media echo chamber of course
followed suit
we are now seeing a term that i never
thought i'd see in my life
fifth columnist
people who are deliberately working to
undermine the american structure really
really close to treason i think doj
should look into people who are russian
propagandists and shilling for putin
well they say that patriotism is the
last refuge of a scoundrel but this is
really despicable
now who needs comedy when you have these
people trying to claim a monopoly on
patriotic fervor over the ukraine
invasion when for the past two years
they've insisted that america's
systemically racist
now biden's own u.n ambassador believes
our very founding is steeped in
wickedness
we have to acknowledge
that we are an imperfect union the
original sin of slavery weaved white
supremacy into our founding documents
and principles biden the secretary of
state he agrees
we know we have work to do at home
that includes addressing profound
inequities
including systemic racism
and our own vice president went even
further
racism is real in america
and it has always been
xenophobia is real in america
and always has been
sexism too
i love how she throws that in at the end
and of course biden just reads whatever
they put in front of him not realizing
the constant america bashing hurts his
credibility and his authority at home
and abroad
racism
the ugly poison that has long haunted
and plagued our nation their systemic
raisins is a stain on our nation's soul
the knee on the neck of justice for
black americans
now wait according to them
ours is a nation with a stain on its
soul it's structurally racist it's
xenophobic and the sexist thing so
how on earth could that america
be the savior for any other country in
distress
and by the way the farce gets better
now they're even extending their treason
narrative to anyone who points out the
fact that gas prices have been rising
way before putin went into ukraine
they are blaming biden for rising gas
prices meanwhile guess who gets off
scot-free not just putin but the big oil
and gas companies and to not blame putin
first of all
is denying reality and second frankly i
think is un-american
now the people now using putin's
inhumane war to demand endless sacrifice
from the taxpayers and then those people
questioning other people's patriotism
now they're the same ones who've spent a
lifetime doing enormous damage to the
fabric of america
now their policies sent millions of jobs
in our industrial base to asia
imported 20 million illegal aliens into
the united states their policies raised
crime rates turned our schools into
propaganda institutes and toppled our
history
in baltimore and little italy the statue
of christopher columbus was removed well
i'm not a bit you know i i don't even
have my grandmother's earrings i'm not
one of those people who's wedded to oh a
statue i don't care that much about
statues
people do what they do
until they build a statue of her she
doesn't care about the statues
well of course people are going to do
what they're going to do and they did
they burned cities they held
neighborhoods hostage they threatened
ordinary americans who didn't chant
their slogans or post supportive
comments on social media
and the elites all the while gave them
cover
a way to end violence
and brutality
and to make sure that people understand
the black lives matter please show me
where it says that protests are supposed
to be polite and peaceful
but now we're supposed to take our
patriotic cues from people like them
no thanks
they will defame you they'll censor you
they'll send your jobs overseas and yet
now they want you to jump on biden's
bandwagon for the war that they'll never
officially get declared in congress
now this is one of the most dishonest
attempts to turn the tables the angle
has witnessed in ages
and they know in their hearts it's not
working
so far biden hasn't received any of the
political capital that uh president
zielenski has offered him at the end of
the day we still remain an incredibly
polarized country you're not going to
give right president biden any credit at
all even if you like what his
administration is doing well biden got
no real bump from the state of the union
and he's not getting much now
that's because americans they do feel
terrible awful about ukraine but they
also feel terrible about a lot of what's
happening to their own country
a new poll out that the press is
feverishly trying to spin as good news
for biden really isn't at least not when
you actually give people the relevant
facts
when yahoo news and yougov asked half of
respondents whether they support or
oppose u.s troops enforcing a no-fly
zone over ukraine with no added context
supporters 40
outnumbered opponents 25 okay but what
happened when the other half of the
respondents were told that a no-fly zone
means that we could actually shoot down
a russian plane possibly trigger even a
war between the u.s and russia well then
support plummeted by nearly half to 23
percent while opposition to that almost
doubled to 43 percent and the biggest
shift came among republicans who went
from supporting a no-fly zone by a
22-point margin to opposing it by a
38-point margin wow facts really do
matter
so are all those americans are they
selfish
are they pro putin traders
now how many of those virtues signaling
with their ukraine flag emojis are
actually uncomfortable with the
enthusiastic flying of the american flag
themselves
but how to separate
american-ness america from whiteness i
was on long island this weekend
visiting a really dear friend and i was
really disturbed i saw you know dozens
and dozens of pickup trucks with uh you
know uh explicatives uh trump flags and
some cases just dozens of american flags
which you know uh is also just
disturbing because essentially the
message was clear it was this is my
country this is not your country
i own this
wow
well we tried to warn the democrats that
they were making a huge mistake by going
so far to the left but they wouldn't
listen
but now the day of liberation is coming
we're gonna have an election on the
first tuesday of this november and then
another in two years and we'll finally
be rid of these fools until then
we have to do everything in our legal
power to protect and conserve what we
still have in america
we don't want american troops dying for
an undeclared war we certainly don't
want to keep spending money we don't
have and we don't want america used as a
base to boost multinational
organizations and the ccp
and we certainly don't feel obliged to
join their false flag patriotism
the establishment bet on the
international order and against the
american people
now
the american people are going to give
them their comeuppance
and that's the angle